gary was a crop duster
[Music]
the best pilot the top gun program had
ever known that's my dad
he walked away from 11 plane crashes a
special kind of wild man
one morning driving to the country
the car had broken down and all of a
sudden
gary jumped off the bridge
what made him do that
people had like theories
i knew it was a shock
but maybe it wasn't inexplicable
i didn't think they talked about
our double life
gary became an international drug
smuggler
and he had made millions and millions of
dollars
it gets complicated your mind has to
switch gears but i never once told the
kids
here's why i ought to have an academy
award
the warren drugs intensified during that
time
in the end this was almost like the tip
of the iceberg
gary was flying guns connected to the
c.i.a i'm in a very dangerous position
right now
my expectations were so high on my dad
that it broke me
you're proud of what you experienced
when you're dealing with that kind of
money people act different
i don't think gary bessner had a clue of
what he was tripping into
one of the biggest political scandals of
his lifetime
[Music]
you